[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as d'information
locale préparé par les équipes de tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 11 octobre voici
les titres de cette édition
retour sur l'élection municipale
partielle à trappes à l'érable a été
réélu maire de la ville au premier tour
ce dimanche le candidat génération point
s a obtenu 58 % des bois mignault
républicaine emmenée par othman menace
roux s'est incliné avec 34% des
suffrages et comme chaque année le mois
d'octobre a revêtu son ruban rose
l'annuel campagne de lutte contre le
cancer du sein revient pour une 28e
édition de nombreux événements seront
organisés dans les yvelines au programme
mach conférences ou encore aux stands
pour sensibiliser et puis découverte du
réseau d'écoles espérance banlieue 17
structures en france destiné aux élèves
décrocheurs de la primaire au collège
nous vous emmenons au coeur de
l'établissement de sartrouville eric
mestrallet fondateur délégué du réseau
espérance banlieue sera avec nous ce
soir
et puis issam d'une quinzaine de
militants de greenpeace france se sont
rassemblés derrière la préfecture de
versailles sur place un stand pour
échanger objectif sensibiliser les
citoyens à la crise climatique notamment
l'impact de l'utilisation des énergies
fossiles en termes de pollution il
dénonce l influence de total energy
compagnie pétrolière française dans ce
domaine une pétition a été lancée à le 4
octobre pour interdire le mécénat et la
publicité pour les combustibles fossiles
près de cinquante cinq mille signatures
ont été récoltées
[Musique]
l'élection municipale partielle à
trappes a rendu son verdict dès le
premier tour ce dimanche 10 octobre la
liste d'allier rabais est arrivé en tête
avec 58 % des voix une victoire pour le
maire élu en 2020 avant de voir son
élection annulée par le conseil d'état
son principal opposant othman al nassr
ou à la tête d'une union républicaine
pour trap a recueilli 34% des suffrages
le reportage de nicolas dandy et ses
liens 400 go
la liste la gauche unie pour que tu
rappes respire menée par ali rabais
vient de remporter l'élection municipale
partielle
il a obtenu 58 % des suffrages des
trappistes la confiance exprimée par les
trappistes est remarquable une victoire
dès le premier tour face à un front
incohérent certes mais qui a été assez
virulent une campagne qui a été violente
dont j'ai été la cible hommes de
calomnie diffamation d'injure répété à
l'origine de ce scrutin partiel
l'annulation des résultats de l'élection
municipale du 28 juin 2020 avec la
victoire d'ali rabais son adversaire
othman nasri avait fait un recours
devant le tribunal administratif pour ce
nouveau scrutin il s'est présenté autour
d'un large rassemblement républicain
avec mustapha larfaoui et l'ancien maire
socialiste guy malandain le candidat de
l'union républicaine pur trap a
recueilli 34% des voix il a réagi par
voie de communiqué ce soir les
trappistes ont choisi de réagir à lire à
b nous n'avons visiblement pas réussi à
convaincre qu'une alternative
républicaine était possible ni a bien
expliqué le double jeu d'al hira b où le
danger des méthodes qu'ils utilisent
nous en prenons acte la liste trappe à
gauche de l'udc miserait a rassemblé 5 %
des suffrages une déception pour le
candidat déjà penché sur son rôle dans
l'opposition on a beaucoup insisté par
exemple sur le thème de l'éducation sur
le fait qu'il fallait plus de qualité
plus de diversité des propositions pour
les enfants on continuera
à défendre ce la dernière liste de ce
scrutin lutte ouvrière faire entendre le
camp des travailleurs avec patrick
planque en tête de liste pour lui le
combat est déjà ailleurs quand on est
travailleur quand on est ouvrier on n'a
jamais rien obtenu par les élections
c'est toujours par nos luttes
collectives et c'est ça qu'on va
défendre dans ces élections c'est ça
qu'on a défendu et qu'on continuera à
défendre pour cette élection partielle
le taux de participation atteint les 41
% un chiffre supérieur au premier tour
de 2020 avec 34 % des votants
à l'occasion d'octobre rose un mois pour
parler du dépistage du cancer du sein la
ville de poissy se mobilise elle propose
plusieurs actions de sensibilisation
implantée à dans la ville la maison les
trois arches est un centre
d'accompagnement des personnes atteintes
de cancer et de leurs proches
aujourd'hui elle a ouvert à ses portes
pour proposer des stands d'information
et des conférences un reportage de
céline charles ouvert en mai dernier
dans le cadre du plan cancer 2 fois ci
la maison les trois arches accueillait
aujourd'hui du public pour sensibiliser
et informer contre le cancer c'est une
maison qui est dédié aux patients
atteints de cancer et aussi aux proches
aux proches aidants c'est une maison qui
propose des soins de support ce n'est
pas une maison médicale c'est une maison
on va dire qui permet d'avoir des
ateliers notamment de socio-esthétique
d'heuliez psychologique sophrologie
atelier alimentation aussi réinsertion
professionnelle aussi au programme
stands d'informations avec des
psychologues des travailleurs sociaux
des associations ou encore des
diététiciens nouveau trois heures c'est
vrai qu'on parle plutôt de soutien
psychologique c'est vraiment s'il ya une
étape de leur parcours le le patient la
patiente ressent le besoin vraiment
d'échangé d'avoir
c'est en des changes pour eux où ils se
remettent au centre aussi et pas juste
sur un versant de soin médical et puis
l'intérêt aussi de ce dispositif ce
qu'on entend beaucoup par rapport aux
personnes qui fréquentent les trois
arches si l'on vit aussi de rencontrer
d'autres personnes c'est un lieu
centralisé où ils peuvent venir où ils
peuvent se sentir en plein de jus
compris et où ils sont pas forcément
d'avoir ils sont pas forcément dans
l'hospitalière l'occasion de rappeler
aussi en pleine campagne octobre rose
l'importance du dépistage du cancer du
sein octobre rose à un mois de
sensibilisation pour le dépistage du
cancer du sein l'idée c'est de rappeler
que c'est important de se faire dépister
le plus tôt possible pour essayer de
traiter le mieux possible la maladie
dont on a beaucoup d'activités on a eu
des marches on a donc des flash mobs on
a des conférences enfin d'être autant
d'activités qui sont là pour rappeler ce
mois qui étreint moi indispensable au
dépistage du cancer du sein d'autres
actions sont prévues au cours du mois à
poissy dont des stands d'information et
des espaces d'échangés 12 21 et 29
octobre prochains
et toujours dans le cadre d'octobre rose
jeudi 14 octobre une marche sera
organisé à rambouillet par la ligue
contre le cancer et l'association gym
marche rambouillet un événement en
collaboration avec le centre régional de
coordination de dépistage des cancers le
centre hospitalier et la mairie de
rambouillet les détails dans cette
interview express de michel poulin est
délégué de la ligue contre le cancer de
rambouillet au micro de sainte-agathe
son dos
[Musique]
d'abord il faut savoir qu'au niveau
international le mois d'octobre c'est
une mois de campagne de sensibilisation
du public au dépistage précoce du cancer
du sein donc en france on nous avons
octobre rose qui a été créée en 1994 et
nous sommes dans la 28e campagne
il s'agit de ne marche
qui sera organisée l'après midi avec un
rassemblement à 13h40 devant la mairie
sur la place de la mairie il y aura
quatre circuits plus ou moins long ça
sera au maximum 7 km 5 et les marcheurs
seront encadrés par les animateurs de
l'association admr donc ras des
personnes pour encadrer les marcheurs le
retour est prévu entre 15h et 16h30
suivant évidemment les longueurs des
circuits
[Musique]
il y aura deux médecins gynéco qui
seront là pour répondre aux questions
des femmes et des personnes qui
souhaitent avoir des informations aux
essarts-le-roi le 15 octobre il y à une
marche intergénérationnelle
et le 17 octobre toujours aux
essarts-le-roi une balade de rose à vélo
avec une tombola organisée chez les
commerçants des essarts le roi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous vous emmenons au coeur
du réseau espérance banlieue à 17 écoles
partout en france destiné aux élèves des
quartiers prioritaires pour en parler
avec nous ce soir eric mestrallet
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes le fondateur délégué du réseau
espérance banlieue
est ce que tu viens vous pouvez nous
présenter ce réseau par la première
école a été fait il ya dix ans donc un
réseau jeunes avec 17 écoles des écoles
qui sont qui vont la maternelle jusqu'à
la troisième la 3 dans les yvelines et
c'est des écoles qui se veulent qu'à
quelques caractéristiques majeures c'est
d'abord des petits effectifs en classe
et au total dans toute l'école maximum
de 150 élèves voilà c'est extrêmement
important parce que ça crée ça peut
créer de la proximité et de l'est de la
une connaissance mutuelle entre les
enfants les parents et le corps
enseignant qui est dédié totalement à
faire en sorte que ces enfants puissent
se déployer déployer leurs talents parce
que chaque enfant a un talent on le sait
bien vous l'avez dit il ya trois écoles
donc dans les yvelines parmi elles celle
de sartrouville donc on a été là bas sa
raison d'être c'est est d'accueillir
donc comme vous l'avez dit des jeunes du
cp au collège en décrochage scolaire ou
en tout cas en prévention de ce
phénomène oui bah forcément de quoi je
suis assez des enfants qui eux qui ont
vraiment besoin de deux un environnement
particulier et surtout des parents qui
souhaitent qu'ils aient un environnement
particulier pour qu'ils puissent se
déployer s'épanouir super et bien
écouter nicolas landry elle s'est rendue
sur place donc c'était au cours charles
péguy à sartrouville regarder
il est 16h15 c'est la fin des classes au
cours charles péguy de sartrouville
c'est l'heure des services ranger la
cour faire la vaisselle nettoyer les
vitres les 79 élèves de l'école sont
répartis dans des équipes internes
niveaux chacune sa tâche pour l'équipe
de stacy c'est le nettoyage des tables
et des chaises de l'école qu'on fait un
service eh bien il faut être toujours
ensemble et non à droite ou à gauche
créée en 2016 cette école fait partie du
réseau espérance banlieue elle compte
sept classes du cp à la 5e marie pierre
collet est enseignante depuis 30 ans
arrivé dans le réseau il ya quatre ans
elle enseigne aujourd'hui à une classe
de cm2 en rep chalet 24 25 élèves c'est
comme si là je vous avais tout le temps
en demi groupe donc on peut se permettre
quand même beaucoup plus de
manipulations en sciences notamment est
d'ailleurs dans toutes les autres
matières en maths enfin voilà on
n'hésite pas à sortir du matériel pour
pour travailler concrètement cet
établissement destiné aux élèves
décrocheurs du primaire au collège c'est
la possibilité pour ces jeunes de
développer aussi un sentiment
d'appartenance les équipes aux noms de
personnalités historiques un uniforme
comme un tout c'est l'hymne national
entonné chaque lundi matin en levant le
drapeau national j'aime bien qu'il y ait
des uniformes et
j'aime bien aussi qu'on s'a semblent
tous les matins
pour ça semble le lundi pour chanter
l'hymne national on travaille bien on
reste comme ça je veux on pourra la voir
alors l'uniforme c'est un vêtement
effectivement que les enfants méritent
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'école ils sont
civile entre guillemets et de par leur
attitude
en classe et à l'extérieur la classe ils
montrent qu'ils ont acquis et qui vous
mettent en pratique les cinq règles d'or
qui sont être joyeux penser aux autres
être propres et ordonnés être vrai et
bien travailler être curieux et ce soir
la cérémonie des avis a permis de
récompenser deux élèves nous n'avons pu
vous voir progresser de jour en jour
depuis le début que vous êtes ici est ce
que vous vous engagez par cette prise
donné forme à respecter les cinq règles
d'or est bien avec une grande joie je
vous le donne donc vous n'aurez plus
qu'à des coûts de votre vécu ton pour
leur remettre la torture
avant de conclure la journée sur le
traditionnel cri de guerre du cours
charles péguy de sartrouville
[Applaudissements]
alors pour ceux qui viennent de nous
rejoindre nous sommes accompagné d'eric
mestrallet donc le fondateur a délégué
les deux réseaux espérance banlieue en
quoi monsieur mestrallet en quoi ces
écoles diffère des établissements
d'éducation nationale alors j'ai évoqué
les petits effectifs à la fois en classe
et d'ensembles établissements dans cet
état dans ces établissements il ya un
corps professoral de d'une dizaine de
personnes et chaque adulte connaît tous
les enfants même s'ils ne les ont pas en
classe et l'enjeu c'est que chaque
adulte soit en mesure de l'identifier
ce qu'un enfant a pu faire de bien et
même si c'est pendant le domaine
scolaire puisque les adultes sont
présents toute la journée au moment de
la récréation
moment de des services comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure ouais donc si on voit un
enfant qui a un talent même s'il n'est
pas scolaire on va le l'encourager lui
donner ça lui permet de prendre
confiance en lui et de et ans et ensuite
à près de 2 le dépanneur d'autres
talents qu'il peut avoir qu'ils sont et
quelquefois un peu enfuis mais il y en a
chaque vraiment de chaque personne à
plein de talent et ce qu'il faut c'est
leur donner la cette capacité à prendre
confiance en eux et il ya les développer
a tout simplement et il faut commencer
peu de petit pas par petit pas
quelquefois on a un enfant très renfermé
qui arrive ça me permet de revenir sur
la qualification vous avez fait de
l'école comme étant que pour des enfants
décrocheurs c'est pas forcément le cas
c'est plutôt des des enfants qui peuvent
avoir des difficultés mais ou qui
peuvent être en souffrance qui ne sont
pas forcément de mauvais mauvais mauvais
à l'école mais ils ont besoin d'un
environnement plus particulier surtout
ils ont besoin et c'est à la demande des
parents l'alliance avec les parents est
extrêmement présente ne pouvoir
construire quelque chose et c'est bien
avec les parents que nous construisons
puisque comme on l'a dit il ya une
dimension éducative mais bien évidemment
c'est d'abord une école dimension
académique et y ait une dimension
connaissance et un vent de la france qui
est extrêmement important pour ces gens
qui se sentent un peu exclu souvent
quand un sentiment est un peu gay au tig
ghettoïser pardon ouais donc l'idée
c'est bah voilà on a la possibilité tous
deux de dette français de comprendre les
codes et donc ayant et tout le monde
peut participer à l'avenir de la france
et c'est dans cette école là un peu
peut-être comme l'école de la troisième
république racon rend compte et qu'on se
donne cette possibilité donc selon vous
c'est important finalement de les faire
s'investir au delà de l'aspect
pédagogique pour qu'il s'épanouisse oui
parce que le talent le talent qu'ils
peuvent avoir et pas forcément premier
dans le domaine domaines académiques et
donc ça peut être un très bon camarade
ça peut être quelqu'un de généreux ça
peut être quelqu'un qui a une
intelligence du coeur
une indigence des situations on sait
bien que chaque être a de multiples
formes d'intelligence et les
intelligences colère quelquefois elle
met plus de temps à se révéler on dit
souvent qu'il faut que les garçons
d'ailleurs
peine un petit peu à la révéler on
traque les filles sont légèrement
meilleures dans plus vite dans le
domaine scolaire donc l'idée c'est juger
une personne en face de moi avec plein
de dimension c'était vraiment important
à prendre en compte c'est qu'il ya une
intelligence mais il ya aussi une
sensibilité il ya des émotions il ya un
physique qui change d'ailleurs beaucoup
au moment de l'adolescence et c'est
c'est un moment qui particulier qu'il
faut qu'il faudra accompagner on
reconnaît dans nos écoles d'ailleurs lé
aussi le fait que chaque enfant les
familles sont très sensibles à ça il ya
une dimension transcendantale de 300
danse quoique que l'on que l'on respecte
mais on en parle à l'école qu'avec les
armes de l'école donc donc voilà donc
c'est quelque chose dont on est bien un
statut aconfessionnel métier qui permet
que ce sujet ne soit pas tabou et et je
pense que les gens sont très contents de
cela et donc là ce sont des classes
interne ivo pourquoi ce choix finalement
non les classes sont des classes
par niveau normal ouais il ya des
équipes inter niveau donc c'est la
dimension pédagogique pendant
éducatif qui est qui est traité de cette
manière là et qui réunit les enfants
avec des grands des moyens et des plus
petits tels manière à développer une
forme d'entr'aide de responsabiliser les
plus grands un peu comme le scoutisme
suis pas si si vous vous connaissez
cette pédagogie qui a fait cas plus de
100 entend maintenant
lancée par baden powell qui a fait ses
ses preuves et donc on a pris des bribes
de 7,2 cette pédagogie pour pouvoir pour
les mettre dans le dans le projet
pédagogique de l'école et et faire en
sorte que ça puisse permettre aux
enfants l'a22 de grandir aussi sur ses
dimensions là les responsabilités
vis-à-vis de d d autres la notion de
fraternité donc une valeur auquel on
tient beaucoup il faut que ce soit est
interdite et vécue au quotidien et même
avec des gens différents qu'on n'a pas
choisi parce qu'ils étaient c'est là où
l'école est vraiment la première société
le premier endroit où on fréquente des
gens que l'on ne choisit pas et c'est
comme la vie ne sera que des rencontres
avec de l'altérité si on ne s'y habitue
pas jeunes ah ben ça sera difficile mais
ça sera la méfiance de la défiance est
souvent de la violence c'est ce que l'on
veut c'est des mines et dès le début de
la vie de ces jeunes et avec leurs
parents donc ça se fait en grande
transparence c'est noté ben écoutez
merci beaucoup je rappelle donc il ya
trois écoles dans les yvelines à
mantes-la-jolie sartrouville et poissy
qui vient d'être inauguré ce vendredi
par des voiles à poissy a été inaugurée
ça faisait un an qu'il existait mais une
belle inauguration et puis et puis à
mantes la gelée bay vous pouvez venir
voir ces écoles parce qu'elles sont
ouvertes donc donc on sera très content
de vous accueillir eh bien écoutez c'est
noté merci beaucoup et avec mistral et
fondateur délégués je le rappel du
réseau espérance banlieue merci au corps
et âme
[Musique]
le 23 octobre prochain la ressourcerie
de guyancourt accueillera ses premiers
clients les équipes finalisent leur
installation ce samedi elle recevait
notamment les personnes intéressées pour
donner de leur temps de manière bénévole
mélanie poké étaient sur place regarder
450 m² de trouvailles à petit prix dans
cette ressourcerie on pourra trouver de
tout pour s'habiller équiper sa maison
l'association ressourcez-vous s'installe
à guyancourt la commune mettant les
locaux à disposition hélas pour objectif
de récupérer les objets que les gens ne
souhaitent plus garder vous aussi les
entreprises ou encore les collectivités
dons qu'elles font de la récupération
aussi auprès de partenaires divers et
variés et ensuite elle a pour objectif
de les réemployer de vous de le
réutiliser en tout cas où si elle ne
peut pas de les recycler vers les bonnes
filières de recyclage des ateliers de
sensibilisation et de réparation seront
aussi proposés cinq à huit salariés de
l'association et en insertion un service
civique et des bénévoles seront aussi
présents sur site les premiers
volontaires été reçu ce samedi pour se
voir présenter la structure et ses
missions quelque chose qui me tenait à
coeur et puis j'ai été élevé aussi dans
cette je dirais éducation où il ne
fallait pas jeter dans la mesure où on
peut données et puis des essaye de faire
pour nos petits enfants nos enfants et
je pense que dans les mentalités il ya
des choses qui changent également je
suis intéressé par le par le concept
delarue la ressourcerie le réemploi et
c'est vrai que l'aspect social en plus
m'intéresse donc voila c'était une
première comme bénévolat un intérêt
certain pour pour la notion de
réutilisation des biens et aussi
proposer éventuellement mes services
dans le cadre de la réparation de
certains biens et la remise en état si
un système de dépôt pourra être mis en
place d'ici trois à six mois la
logistique actuel de la ressourcerie ne
permet pour le moment pas d'apporter des
dons ouverture des portes au public le
23 octobre prochain
et avant de conclure cette édition une
disparition celle d'à bola san bani sadr
premier président de la république
islamique d'iran vous le voyez sur ces
images de nos confrères d'ign une
première qu'il avait rencontré dans sa
résidence protégée à versailles en 2012
après la révolution de 1979 intime de
l'ayatollah khomeini il est élu
président de la république islamique d
iran en 1980 est destitué 17 mois plus
tard est contraint à l'exil à cause de
ses positions démocratique il arrive en
france et obtient l'asile politique en
1981 il s'installe dans une résidence
sous protection policière à versailles
dont laquelle il résidera jusqu'à sa
disparition ce samedi à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière à paris à l'âge de 88
ans
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant retrouver michael almy d'euros à
la présentation de votre magazine
sportif très bonne soirée at sur tv 78
[Musique]